yippee
road trip who's excited to go to
bloomington is that where you're gonna
sit
i'm driving where else would i sit trunk
i thought you weren't gonna do
valentine's day this year because that
she beast moved away i believe her name
was satan her name was anne oh the gps
says we should take 495 to 270. but
check out this cool alternate route my
god that is so interesting to me because
i'm a map salesman i will photoshop his
face can you photoshop your life with
better decisions jerry okay where's your
costume
honey he's wearing a costume he's going
as lame andy just wants you to be proud
of him and his music so
this isn't really about being right it's
more about being supportive
oh wow i didn't realize you were a
marriage counselor anne
sorry
my instinct is to be mean to you i
understand i want another nurse well
there are none we're stretched pretty
thin right now then i want a janitor
they can do what you do right
yep nurses and janitors are totally
interchangeable except no one dresses up
like a janitor when they want to be
[ __ ]
i actually think you look really good
except for the
stick up your butt what do you think
druid was it nathaniel
ellis
man i feel like these interns do not
respect or like me at all honestly you
could loosen up a bit on the font stuff
and everything in general
uh
oh wow look at that
did you draw that uh nope i didn't no no
no it's really good i mean you're
a
you're
a great artist i can't do this look
i don't care who you're related to i'm
your boss and you can't keep
disrespecting me like this man i didn't
draw
it your daughter did it
what
her
april's not my daughter she's my friend
does everyone think she's my daughter
whatever
point is she would never do that to me
sorry dad
i love games that turn people against
each other
you guys will never believe what i just
found on jerry's facebook a friend burn
so are you gonna vote for me
sister april it's unethical for me to
show you favoritism
you and i are like family
coffee is seven dollars yes right of
course you might be able to sneak out
early you get snacks i'll bring music
we'll jam out to some sweet tunage you
know what this is awesome actually no i
don't want to go anymore oh
okay just kidding see you in 10 minutes
okay just kidding we're not going
road trip so we're going yes
where's jerry by the way why isn't he
back how long does it take to fill bird
feeders maybe he fell into the toilet
remember when he fell into the toilet
oh sorry guys sorry i'm late i got
confused and took a shower after i got
dressed because i'm jerry
i thought you might like a fresh set of
pillows
are you trying to smother me
help the [ __ ] nurse is trying to
smother me to death with a pillow
okay never mind stay back [ __ ] do you
like my nails
april you finalized a rental right shut
up anne i told you never to talk to me
that was champion oh my god i'm sorry
bad dog yes everything's fine with the
rental ben you know that i despise you
and that i want you and all people on
earth to be miserable right sure what
does leslie always say i don't know
weird stuff about waffles come on april
get in here peace come on do it get
somebody i don't care about that prize
but i'm gonna win because i want his
happiness to go away
are you getting ready for your nightly
skype date with andy and london you look
lovely i'm going to murder you a
thousand times okay there's always been
a little distance between me and april
and i thought this would maybe i don't
know give us a chance to
get a little closer
maybe even i don't like anne
soundtrack to pulp fiction
soundtrack to singles
soundtrack to gross point blank why do
you have so many soundtracks oh well uh
i kind of look at it like it's your
favorite director's making a mixtape
just for you oh hey ann are you still a
nurse or did they fire you because you
slept with all the doctors do you want
to try that again hey i'm thinking about
getting a new phone do you guys like
your phones i've never used a phone in
my life
i'm just an impartial bunny but i think
anne sucks also i'm the zodiac killer
hey
dude do you play ultimate yeah i play
intramural at georgetown dude so did i
in college whoa you guys should get
married
[Music]
my blankets are on the floor
do you want the door open or shut uh
opens fine okay
i hope you like toriyamas oh cool
what and i just stole your phone and
texted every guy in it that the baby was
there it's not that big of a deal data
had never felt this way before of course
data had never felt anything before but
captain picard couldn't help but note
the smile that crept over his mechanical
but lifelike face i'm gonna murder you i
understand just one sec as they walked
down the hall into the bridge we have a
couple house rolls though yeah sure of
course you can't use the front door you
have to climb in through the back window
no personal phone conversations if you
ever speak to me in spanish please use
the formal uth dead and no electricity
after 6 pm
she's joking okay you can use as much
free electricity as you want it's free a
couple more rules if you ever watch a
sad movie you have to wear mascara so we
can see whether or not you've been
crying
there's no noise a lot on mondays and no
tv after breakfast hey april i was
looking to get some new music and i was
wondering if you could recommend
anything
the internet i really like your haircut
where where'd you get it prison how's
your sister doing she has the shingles
who's your favorite character on sex in
the city
alf
yeah i love cup gangs
alice hates you annie has herpes
if what's your problem my problem is you
smell us ben told you to finish the
website and if you don't do it i swear
to god i'm gonna murder you in your
sleep i know where you live 14th street
right i'm gonna get a melon baller and
scoop your eyes out and eat them and
your congressman uncle's gonna have to
buy you a dog to drag your eyeless face
around
do you understand me
yes
do it
okay
i wanted to make fun of stupid people
while i get drunk
my two true passions
oh
being nice made me feel terrible i took
ron's advice i very maturely and
straightforwardly left anonymous
comments about donna online
it's kind of weird when she just starts
raining compliments on you huh don't try
to bond with me
i can't win is your name glenn yeah i
sat behind you in middle school band do
you still play the clarinet
yeah
have you been man
so i long for a day when women in
government will simply be seen as people
in government but until then i will work
to make pawnee my wonderful hometown as
good as it can be
what do you think i think you should
lose the first line and the last line
and all of the other lines and instead
just walk up to the mic and meow really
loudly for eight minutes okay
anne's leaving town
and saying painful goodbyes to loved
ones greatest day of my life
you